Aaron Jones of the Green Bay Packers how
are you Eric I'm good thank you for
having me oh no thanks for coming back
again and certainly when you ball out
like that as prime would say you get the
call right here from the Rich Eisen show
for sure why did you say that about
being able to go yard for yard with Zeke
prior to the game this weekend I mean as
an athlete and competitor you want to
report a shoe comes up to you ask you do
you think you can go yard for yard with
this guy as a competitive athlete I am
I'm not going to say now I believe in
myself and I believe in my abilities and
it's not just this week it wasn't a Zeke
I aim to go out there every week to be
the best best back on the field and what
were you able to do this week that you
put it all together I guess in a way
that we had yet to see over the first
month of the season probably all started
with the blocking unit the guards our
own are they they did the job they made
it easy for me to just run in fine lanes
and go on touch sometimes and when you
can do that it's gonna be a good day
there's gonna be a lot of fun out there
and what was it like for you in terms of
fun walk me through the day oh oh man it
was it was amazing I had my family there
close to 30 people back home in Texas so
that's the closest they'll get to see me
play and just um just knew it was gonna
be a good day something Adele from the
moment I woke up and then game gets
kicked off and we get to go and I get a
couple touchdowns early and I get going
I'm starting to make people miss and I
just knew I was in the zone I was about
to ask you about being in the zone how
does that feel different from other
games it just when you get the ball in
your hand you're just you're just making
plays I mean you're making people
measured you just in the zone you're
you're you're that playmaker right then
in that moment and that's not knowledge
that she try to achieve every time I
step on this is what you are in the zone
does that what causes you to wave
goodbye to a defender that's trying to
chase you down in the end zone
Allen oh yeah definitely I mean um you
know when you're out there the game gets
chippy you guys get to talk in and
usually I'm not a guy who talks trash
unless you talk trash to me first so um
then I don't stop talking
you're gonna hear me flute after the
game but it was no disrespect to Byron
zonal he's a great players just had a
little fun in the heat of the moment so
are you saying there was a lot of Jones
on Jones chatter throughout the day
no no not Jones but I just the game in
general everybody who could I mean
alright put me down on the field here
Aaron what were they saying a little bit
of everything so you can't say on air
okay it definitely is chippy I mean you
your competitors you want to win you're
out there it's almost like a fistfight
you're out there blocking each other
trying to get off blocks so it's gonna
get chipping they're gonna get physical
in that's a part of the game well no I
understand that but I mean how can
anybody start barking at you the way
that you got off and then continued to
just dominate in the game Aaron I don't
know but it kills me it keeps it keeps
me going today just like this is like
adding fuel to the fire so I mean how do
I take it Aaron Jones here on the Rich
Eisen show and again you played your
college ball at UTEP that's that's why
this was a home game for you essentially
right or I know you were born in
Savannah I don't know what your Texas
history is other than that you went to
school there yes I moved there in
seventh grade went to middle school high
school and stayed there for college and
my family still lives there so because I
say I'm from El Paso this where home is
for me that's where my heart is and the
people there show me nothing but love
and respect and support and it's a lot
of cowboy fans there but Aaron John's
hands as well ha so did you shut a lot
of people up do you think I think I did
tell my dad I said we got a little
bragging rights when we go back home now
that's great what would that
seventh-grader move to Texas and has
been surrounded by Cowboys fans his
whole life what would that
seventh-grader have thought if somebody
walked up to you and said hey one day
four touchdowns for the Packers in the
home of the Dallas Cowboys Aaron Jones
I probably would have said at the time
when I was 12 years old I probably said
uh no I'll Poli scored four touchdowns
for the Cowboys so I love it I'm honored
and blessed to be a packer I wouldn't
want to be anywhere else and so now that
sort of your kid is that was definitely
during about scoring four touchdowns
against it's a routine growing up so so
much has been mentioned Aaron Jones
about the Packers this year and the
offense and Matt Lafleur being brought
in after what we saw with Mike McCarthy
for a dozen years you were not there for
those doesn't fall for all the dozen
years but so much has talked about
change of culture is there been a
culture change in that locker room air
oh you could just definitely tell the
difference in a locker room is there's
more energy around here there's more of
a family by God our thing and all way
more just is just a whole different
energy and I think it starts with coach
Tom he came in and just commanded the
room and we all bought in and we know
this is one big family and it just it
just trickled down in it's showing on
the field I mean the office makes a play
there also bring together the defense
makes the play they're all celebrating
together we're all happy for each other
and that wasn't really the case all the
time in previous couple years no not
that it wasn't it just wasn't stressed
as much um and you can just tell that
this year is just like the different of
I like it there's one big family I mean
I've hung out with so many guys on the
team this year that I hadn't hung out
with last year and it's just when you
get that it's like you're playing with
53-52 other brothers next to you you'd
do anything for and and again I know I
might need to take it up with the other
Aaron Aaron Jones but on occasion we do
see I guess a family conversation might
be it could be called between Aaron
Rodgers and Matt Lafleur can you tell me
what if I was a fly on that wall what it
would sound like Aaron Oh
it would just be um them to trying to
get the best play that they can do we
want to score every every chance and
when you have a great quarterback like a
row
we have the ability to score every play
so just then communicate and try to get
to the right call or what they seen on
that play so that's what that's what I'm
hearing
okay yeah cuz I saw there was one
towards the middle of the game last week
and Geronimo Allison was just staring
straight ahead like he wasn't he didn't
want to seem to be wanting any part of
that conversation you know but we you
know we have eaten heated conversations
here every now and then but then we just
because we just want to put the best the
best show together you know yes all
about being the best you know I know so
okay so now it comes down to it can you
go yard four yard with Kerry on Johnson
Aaron um I'm not just carrying on but
any backing League I'm so like I'm one
of the best backs early so I said if it
gets any back I love that see I was
trying to just get you to do something
for just the Monday night game but when
it all comes down to it though you have
to speak it into existence you have to
believe it and there's so many others do
you know this is a key and are you
feeling that there's more plays being
called for you now in that regard um
last week yes so I definitely did I'm
just in the place I didn't that wasn't a
game plan or anything that's just the
way the game had sorted itself out and
you keep hearing when you're in the
huddle you keep hearing a plate you're
the play calling you your this your
number you know okay lock in go to work
be the playmaker when it all comes down
to it Aaron Jones you had a huge game
man and I really appreciate you calling
in to this show your you always have a
spotter you don't have to score four
touchdowns every time but I'd love to
check back in with you later on in this
season that has started out just
dynamite for your team and then
obviously this past week for you yes sir
definitely I would love to come back on
office after another four touchdown game
well I mean how about a 5-1 I mean I'm
definitely cool with five I do have to
have full disclosure here okay
now full disclosure here's full
disclosure my fantasy team stinks I mean
it blows it really it's just it's
terrible I'm was on for coming into this
week and it couldn't
couldn't have I could not have needed to
win any more than I needed it this week
and coming into the late afternoon
everybody on my team had played except
for Ezekiel Elliott and I was 12 points
behind the other team that had played
everybody except for let me look this
guy's name up Aaron Jones is his name
and what you did not only destroyed the
Cowboys it destroyed me I mean like
absol everything GLE time I look down at
my phone I'm like again so I have to
fully disclose your that did not keep me
from wanting you on this show I
appreciate that
okay well look man keep doing your thing
keep doing your thing okay yes sir thank
you for having me and it's good to talk
to you again right back at you that's
Aaron Jones at Showtime underscore 33
but the ion Showtime is with a why for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app